Iowa held its first in the nation
caucuses on Monday night with record
turnout find out who won and who's out
with reasons three takeaways from the
Iowa caucuses a first conservatives vote
for Ted Cruz usually I say polls are
only good for strippers and
cross-country skiers but in this case I
do think that the polls are accurate
well Sarah Palin was almost right the
top GOP contenders in the polls did take
the top three spots but those who
identify as strong conservatives which
were four out of ten Republican caucus
goers broke for Cruz and gave the Texas
senator a comfortable win over Donald
Trump with twenty eight percent of the
vote thanks to the incredible hard work
of everyone gathered here of courageous
conservatives across this state we
together earn the votes of 48,000 608
Iowans the biggest surprise of the night
was Marco Rubio's strong third place
finish almost tying Trump with
twenty-three percent of the vote Rubio
showing now makes him the favorite among
the establishment candidates at number
two did Hillary get burned Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders ended up in a
dead heat Monday night with each
candidate getting about fifty percent of
the vote this gives Sanders momentum
going into next week's New Hampshire
primary where he leads Clinton by a wide
margin granted Hillary has a number of
super delegates in her back pocket and a
solid nationwide ground game but her
performance in the caucus shows that
voters aren't necessarily sold on
Clinton as the nominee and that the
Democrats have a race on their hands our
final takeaway Iowa pics losers well at
least for Republicans Iowa correctly
predicted the Democratic nominee when
Obama went on to carry the state in 2008
but by and large Iowa is a terrible
barometer when it comes to predicting
the future GOP nominee since 1976 only
three caucus winners became the eventual
Republican nominee the last was George W
Bush back in two thousand the good news
for everyone is now that voting is
underway the field will narrow Mike
Huckabee and Martin O'Malley have
already suspended their campaigns now if
we could just get rid of the rusted
clowns